in the beginning uh there were a lot of
people like Martin you're too young it's
not going to work if I release a new
track there would be 99 good comments
and one bad one and I would be like why
would someone say that if you always
play it
safe it's boring life life will get
boring he's a Dutch DJ record producer
and musician he gained Fame through his
song Animals which became popular in the
EDM culture he's ranked number one on DJ
mag's top 100 DJ list Martin Garrick and
here's my take on his top 10 rules for
Success rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
you as well
enjoy
you know what have you learned from your
success so far maybe
um that's all about hard hard working I
think and trusting in what you're doing
because in the beginning uh there were a
lot of people like know Martin you're
too young it's not going to work and uh
also at my uh my soccer team there I was
I was DJing and they
like and right now they're like oh dude
you you're right and
I think that's that's the most important
thing if you believe in what you're
doing that's the most important thing if
you don't believe in what you're doing
you can give you you need you give up
you you don't have to uh put time and
effort in it because it won't work my
life lesson would be
um just always focus on the positive
stuff every every time there's like
something negative and I used to like
focus on all the negative stuff and then
like for example there would be like uh
if I release a new track there would be
99 good comments and one bad one and I
would be like like why would someone say
that and just only focus on the one bad
comment but for me what really helped
was for me just to like forget like
don't even pay attention to the negative
stuff just always focus on the positive
side I feel like if you're not taking
risk not taking risks you're doing
something wrong if you always play it
safe it's boring life life will get
boring and I I feel like taking risk is
exciting it's it's because you don't
know what's going to happen and to me
that feeling is
is a great feeling and also like with
anything in life I feel like if you want
something to happen you need to take
risk you need to try new things you you
you don't be scared what do you want to
say to your fans that are asking like yo
like are you still going to make that
high BPM uh you know Festival music to
leave are you leaving that for more I'm
not leaving anything mainstream or can
you explain that transition and what
you're doing there for me it's all about
trying to find new sounds reinvent
venting your own sound I can I can I can
release 128 BPM Club song every every
week but I I don't know I want to
challenge myself in the studio I want to
try out new things I want to experiment
and me trying out something new and
doing something like scared to be lonely
or Name of Love doesn't mean I'm
completely switching my sound I like in
October I just released seven like very
aggressive 128 BPM house songs and I've
got Ultra coming up I've got Coachella
coming up and I'm going to also play a
lot of old sounding morning G stuff but
it's it's a weird situation cuz then I
released a house song one year ago and
they're like oh same rep repetitive
boring stuff uh try something do
something new be refreshing and I do
something new and they're like we missed
the old Mar Garrick and I'm like wait
what you guys want me to do but for me
what I think is most importantly is just
me being myself in the studio doing what
I want
and don't let other people's opinions
affect my music I I I want to represent
what I want to make and I'm not
switching my sound I'm just having fun I
start focusing more on the studio just
trying to find my own sound if I had a 1
hour or 2 hour break at school I would
run to my house and then work or
something this is some stuff I did in
2008 sounds like but pretty fun hair
back for me producing music was just my
Martin time I could spend 12 hours just
behind my computer in my room never
really with the mindset of like oh I
want to make money or I want to become
famous if I look back at a time I see a
little kid just enjoying everything and
doing what he
loves sounds super unprofessional super
bad mix super bad sounds but it's funny
it's a timeline to My Life as a producer
it's pretty
[Music]
cool what's my biggest advice is if
you're in it for the wrong reasons don't
even try to get famous
because very small chances will happen
and in the end when you're producing
music uh what I had a lot was I would
send my songs to a bunch of labels and
get no reply and would feel like for
like a a couple of weeks and in the
studio I would be like insecure like is
it that bad or if I put all the time I
put sending the songs into the label if
I put all the energy that I put into
that into producing I would have known
what I know right now like maybe two
years ago but apart from the financial
success of the Garrick brand the
19-year-old still says that it really is
just about the music for me I don't
measure success in money money is
something which comes along with it but
for me I measure success in in releasing
a song and getting getting like
uh super super many views like good
feedback about the fans and the fact
that you can do shows for more people
and in the end I'd rather I'd rather
look look on like how a show is going or
how a tour is selling like how many
people want to see me how people visit
how many people visit the shows how many
people watch like the videos
online that that means so much more than
just a number of money it sounds so
cheesy but it's like full of your dreams
for me I have a 100% belief in if
somebody really wants something and
really has the really is eager to work
hard for it you can you can make it
happen or you can at least be very very
close you know so
yeah it sounds cheesy follow your dreams
and spend as much time as you can trying
to improve get better learn new things
and it's never too late to learn new
things and for me still every day I get
to learn new things and that's that's
the fun thing you never know everything
what I had trouble with was that No
Label wanted to sign my stuff the first
four years five years and and every time
I had a track I was like oh this track
is amazing and then I send it to all the
labels and I would get no reply and as a
producer it's the most frustrating thing
ever especially when you think like oh
this track can be a hit I just need a
good label but right now if I listen
back to the tracks I'm like of course
the labels didn't reply but I was always
too like stuck up on like oh label
didn't reply and I wouldn't produce for
two weeks because I felt bad and then I
was like a I'll try it again I'll open
the program so my advice is definitely
like try to keep better get better get
better spend as much time as you can in
the studio and the labels will find you
instead of you for the next top 10 video
please check the description for a link
to a video where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down in the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Grant from mohos coffee.com Grant thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word I really really
appreciate the support and I hope you're
enjoying the to read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you
soon how many hours a day are you busy
with music uh all the hours I'm not
asleep it's like literally I wake up but
also listening to
music yeah I music is everything to me
you live and breathe it yeah the
collaboration with sharan came about um
yeah I was I I met him a couple of times
and we were talking about music and I
sent him some some some ideas some
Melodies and then suddenly he recorded a
voice note on WhatsApp like uh from him
like singing rewind repeated like the
first super old version of it and I
liked it he recorded it he sent it to me
I made a track around it then he readed
the vocals or changed a little it was
it's really cool we've been in the three
times together two two times to to
properly finish a track we recorded some
of his guitar as well which which is
also in the track so it's really a
collaboration and the cool thing is like
he comes from such a different he has
such a different vision and I got a
different Vision um so like sometimes we
had to like he's he's here he's here and
we had to agree in the middle and it was
super cool I learned a lot from the
process and it's also interesting as as
a producer to see how someone else
thinks how someone else works it's it's
very uh learnable it's really nice